last week just you and we finally fix
the bin before but it came with a price
[Music]
this video is dedicated to my editors my
brand's there's old boy is roasting time
finally finally I'm not the butt of the
joke hey Brad 1 & 2 huh you're trying to
make him look bad huh is that what you
try to do Brad I spend so much time and
effort and money resources skill
knowledge to find the right camera and I
do it and they don't even color
corrected is this so hard learn color
correction I think the thing about this
whole color correction thing is it used
to be a joke that I had really bad
quality on my videos but now that I
finally got better quality I think
people maybe took it a bit far people
are actually uh neurotically really
pissed off they're trying to make him
look like the NiO during the scene where
he is still in the matrix the last meme
review was probably the most poorly
edited video on Felix Channel he was
laughing at one meanwhile a different
one yes it's editor roasting time no
more Thank You PewDiePie Frick you Brad
how dare you edit my videos every single
day yeah I don't know how that happened
but lastly why I was basically reacting
to video sale watching this person try
to unlock oh cool cool
good edit Brad huh I'm not even reacting
to this meme you dumb my you dumbest
schmuck everyone's like Oh Felix of dumb
Oh oh really why am i roasting my
employees like this I'm just trying to
deflect okay we were so focused on T
series that we didn't actually then
realise Peters has been missing for mine
it's almost like I wanted to avoid just
a little bit of controversy just for a
few weeks how about that that's right
everyone two weeks of
I know controversy mm-hmm that's a new
record
if minecraft world is infinite how does
that son get around it did Elin really
tweet this goddamn this is how you know
he's so smart this is how you know he's
thinking about rockets and cuz he knows
mind that makes no sense
what infinite +1 every meme dies
eventually this mean now what that brick
it's no longer roasting Brad time it's
roasting whoever uploaded this garbage
meantime it's supposed to be Ricardo you
dummy dumb bums Sonic or Sonny oh my god
the new Sonic looks amazing Wow
the Pixar team animation has reached out
and they've helped out paramount
incredible job I want to do a Photoshop
where I just Photoshop different version
of Sonic I think that could be funny my
second attempt to feech oh my god I
don't believe this I reacted to this
lastly why and I remember it this
confirms that Brad is trying to
purposely sabotage this channel first we
thought it was a joke that the quality
was bad
they've been clearly doing it on purpose
they've been editing wrong means maybe
purposely not color correcting what is
stitch I love this fine art it's super
cool look they even drew Brad come on
and look they even drew Simon there this
is so sad I could not meet PewDiePie
but I found a suitable replacement I'm
Papa Gloria what a lot of people don't
know is that any time I'm on an
interview and doing anything I just sent
up Papa Gloria because we look so
similar it's so strange that she looks
exactly like me when someone stole your
meme and got 21 thousand point 7 up
votes
you took everything from me who's this
girl the most uninteresting character
I've ever seen I don't even know who
that's me I'm on their side
I drew my chin
oh I bet Brides gonna edit this one I
edit this one out Brad it's much yeah I
don't care a wonderful artist oh oh wow
I wonder what he's draw
if you draw me Sonic wow it looks just
like her I'm glad so many people finally
and appreciate my artistic skills
because goddamn is that a beautiful
sonic I think even lust sucks he drew it
right where is it there ace 10 out of 10
beautiful see how I capture the teeth
if paramount picture comes up with this
Sonic you know I'm I'll be copy striking
you need 3000 IQ to understand this good
thing I have three thousand and one I am
wrote I am NOT I am NOT so I am not
supposed to get I am not supposed to get
my opinion but 3000 IQ thank you very
much please stop making these alright my
brain is gonna explode at some point
what a mad line props to this guy this
man lost his son to a traffic accident
because caused by one of the many
potholes in India so now he fills in
potholes himself so other people don't
lose for these damn sad but also
commendable I'm not good at color
correction but I had to do this better
than their original look at that damn
could I have that quality is that
actually possible wow this is the raw
footage this is how it looks like I give
them the raw footage and they make it
look so bad like my footage is so good
okay moving on next meme when you met
Pierce in real life and he's 181 and
you're 180 alright time to stop that
tall meme
okay I had enough what's up
regular-sized man you break an arm it's
cool you break an ass it's not cool
take it from me I'm so disappointed I
even have the ass outro in that video
missed opportunity of perfect
advertising oh yeah
Brad adds the outro good job Brad a
story that we waited long for I broke my
hair yes I should have used that as a
thumbnail off jeez thanks Brad big brain
plate I got a letter in the post hmm
what is this Brad can't cut out our
memes if peopIe
now this is it next week the white will
be live-streamed of D life okay no
longer will our memes be unedited no
longer with our color correction B not
great this is the time we fight back
Thank You Bradford editing in this video
the same day I send it to you by the way
because I forgot to send the video to
you this man broke his ass in a boating
accident so he spent the past 16 years
designing a comfortable chair so other
people don't feel the pain he felt wow
what a great guy that must be and I'm
sure he's also very tall
I drew p5 Mart's yeah I stayed up all
night to do this I hope you like it
I love it you captured my hair and
everything ten out of ten baby twenty
nine thousand people agree now some
people would say this is ugly but art is
subjective and you're wrong dumbass
paramount new render of Sonic
look dope am absolutely 10 out of 10 the
fact that I wasn't asked to be in the
film in this costume really disappoints
me oh yeah we did in an a we did an ad
for our key driving car the cringe I
think I got second or something I'm such
a trihard it's like oh god we have to do
this really awkward promo what should I
do to make it more interesting I'll
dress up at Sonic what a great idea
should we write Thank You pity pie on
the next SpaceX launch Wow
stop it come on you don't have to do
that it's whatever you wait we've got
about ha ha ha you should make is the
hare little longer and more sad and
depressing characters before and after
pretty pie video oh my god I true the
dolphin so well I can't get over how a
messed up handsome Squidward's face
I love disgusting what is that thing I
made a custom beautify 100 millions of
my reward just waiting to engrave the
date on it should I send it to pooch
that's amazing thank you so much will
YouTube recognize that I exist wait for
a hundred million and we'll find out
sad beautify doses ask doctor we'll fix
your pens too late
15 years too late is that an actual
quote from the film if so 10 out of 10
mean ask doctor where were you when I
needed you ask doctor doesn't use legs
it's cool oh you think I'm cool of thank
you hovers to race I'm hot poor foolish
people about hi how could we have been I
don't know who this guy is but I like
him okay I like him a lot
oh my god I can't believe it paramount
shame on you
PT PI probably won't understand god damn
it okay alright
pew rip pew die pie pew die pie
we'll all wave all wave be always be
numbers number one sub are number one in
our heart
Thank You 9 year olds for another epic
episode of love why now more mediocre
content will come so please do subscribe
let's get to a hundred million and let's
freakin do this broski's brofist it will
be for God until a hundred see you guys
then what you never played super
simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
convinced yet okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]